what is up this is take 2 for Thursday
and guess what it's take 2 because
there's two people on the show it's
logotherapy welcome back to the show
ladies and gentlemen today on today's
show we're gonna review two logos from
two amazing designers that I really
admire it's two by two first up is
Markus wrench
you guys can reach out on Instagram at
Marcos underscore wrench he's from
Hamburg Germany he does amazing really
beautiful work he's a regular on our
show now as is her deal she's on her
show too he deals the returning champion
and you could see her on Instagram at
hadeel s Ahmad
she's from Amman Jordan here's her work
and she does lovely work so let's just
dive right into it thank you everybody
for your patience today up first is you
hung FA you hung fate and it's for NEC
civil engineers soccer club I got that
right this time Marcus welcome to the
show how you doing all right
you bring the fire today yeah so I'm
starting again rip the video start again
let's do it
okay just open it up in Photoshop
very quick and you can see - this it
looks a bit odd you shape it so they're
just too complicated for me so I like
it's simple and trying to sketching
something simpler so I'm starting with
the sketch and I'm putting two young
rich on top as I said before I think he
picked a bridge to showcase what
engineers are doing and mm-hmm
I think that is yeah are you basing this
on any kind of bridge in particular just
the idea of a bridge I think just a
bridge in general so the idea guess yeah
I try different types of britches and my
sketches just to look what looks best
what is working good mm-hmm
no I'm just sketching real quick yeah
and as we mentioned before it's it's a
little tricky to read that as civil in
the original badge but read CVL because
the legs of the bridge connect with the
eyes of the word civil so I appreciate
you pulling it out so legibility really
important right all right that was my
intention so I think it was yeah he
wanted to to do it like that but I think
it's that good to read it in smaller
sizes or something like that not right
so I was like I have to separate those
two elements and in the second sketch I
was like what if I just put the football
or soccer ball right in the center and
just one that's like a different type of
bridge with the hanging
stripes I don't know how it's called I
think suspension bridge or some friend
and it's called the ascension bridge
very good pretending to be um balls like
now I looked it up [ __ ] I got this
beautiful yes so I was like maybe I make
a fruit sketch and I'm just combining
those two shapes into a new one so just
make it a little curved and just maybe I
just well I was like wait what if I just
um put one single tower in the center of
the batch so maybe it's more clearly
similar so also the other shape of the
batch is works quite well with the
kind of rich type so as you can see um I
think this one looks or cure I I like
that little line that you cut into the
arc of the bridge now it makes it all
dimensional yeah you guys see that
little thing you did a little magic
eraser or whatever you did was like boom
there it is so can I just ask you just
honestly are you recording this
in real time or did you work it out
first and then go back and rerecord it
and this one was with them but I played
like four times faster so okay so this
is really you working through the
problem but just really yeah okay yeah
right right
awesome so is that the place where the
soccer ball gear thing is gonna go yes
exactly
so no hold it tight and I think this one
works quite well so I think I'm gonna
use this shape mm-hmm because it's um
it's it's bold mm-hmm and it's simple so
it's nice so you take it mm-hmm people
are saying they love the option the
third option and they'd like to see your
process very nice big right up into
Australia and creating a new file and
yeah starting with the lip the shape
itself
I know just export is real quick so I
have a look at it in my illustrator file
mm-hmm mmm export is all right so so I'm
just what's just a bit slow so we
created from scratch because I need that
these redone design from sketch again
why I would call it yesterday so I was
like what the hell I'm doing so I had to
fast from time to time like this it's
like what the hell and I'm doing so
okay so you didn't trace over it you're
gonna redraw it again in Illustrator
yeah okay why'd you do it this way this
time I don't know I don't like it when I
just um paints my sketch and then build
it with illustrator
it's just I don't know it's just so
messy it does not work for me so I don't
okay just that's just your process how
you do just my process yeah I notice
you're working on a grid right now right
like snaps integrate every time mm-hmm
hashtag grid forever
that's right yes so I just tried to make
the shape even maybe just a little more
curved
mm-hmm yeah just no just much of a hair
so okay so no make a compound path no
hefty the basic shape and then I um you
see ya Sara saying hashtag grids life
that's a much better hashtag good life
yes
and also I'm starting with the tower of
the bridge and try to figure out how I
just did it in the first place I'm like
okay there's something like this okay
somebody was asking when you were
sketching to use a tablet and stylus or
each using a mouse I use a Wacom tablet
yeah
Wacom here that there's a sponsorship
opportunity right there for both of us
what we great because I use a very very
old tablet it's like a welcome that's
perfect yeah we need to call him up but
normally I just look at that you added
another shadow on the other side of it
oh yeah that was there in the original
sketch wasn't it I just didn't see you
there very nice
okay think now just now Jen make stripes
and I think after that I'm ready to go
to start with the bike so alright did
you calculate how many grid spaces this
is going to be wide to get even stripes
at the bottom
yes you did
I redid do the whole shady because I was
like in veins like to two columns -
right right yeah I see you guys see you
panting ahead there because you know
that you have what is that one two three
four you have to have seven right seven
stripes at the bottom with one in the
center you get the plan and stuff out
otherwise it's gonna be a little weird
on the sides and we see this when people
submit logos to us we were like whoa
what's up with the tangency like why
don't you guys calculate this in your
design a little more precision right
changing it
and what type things are using there for
civil education I use sea monster out
because it's so nice it's a good form
the original design used he'll be two
kids nothing nothing's won with that but
you know it was just not I don't like
the I can see from if you look up in
engineers by the way a is Beltran there
yeah but the are is already Vinick ah it
has this little swoosh mm-hmm I don't
like that you like the straight leg are
yeah mm-hmm you said it's monserrate is
the typeface yeah is that a free
typeface yeah it's a Google phone yeah
actually it's a good nice bold chunky
sans-serif typeface I like it it reminds
me a little bit of Gotham right right
yeah you like the our little our it's
nice to have those options and in a San
serif typeface with this particular
letters it's hard to find something
that's interesting unique so the R is
the one that's where I gonna stand out a
little bit yeah that's right
I just forgot to Nike stock up on us so
I have had to redone this from scratch
so I was like me okay
so I took a wise so don't Josh you
trying to tell the internet not to judge
come on let's be realistic here it's
gonna have it don't judge don't see them
right there you go don't judge too
quickly is all we're gonna say hmm I
think I can speak this a little bit up
so okay hmm
there's my soccer ball
you gonna fill it with white yep that's
right
then will you add an outline to that mmm
I thought it's just um it stands crack
without as it is because and at the end
I was like engineering day and got more
different feels engineering right occur
like what if from electric engineering
is also some feel of interviews or was
like me it just put a little electricity
like involved in there yeah on the bone
yeah so it kind of looks like a light
bulb at the same moment oh yeah I see
that
late night canvas is saying it's funny
that you think that took a while for me
this would have taken nine hours even
sped up it's okay we're all working at
different paces guys don't worry don't
compare your worst to somebody's best
it'll be all right I'm here for you
so now you're adding some colors in here
this is the original color palette yep
that's the original colors and yeah
that's the final design and then I was
like me what if we take another nother
one like I'm different
they're from yellow not right and then
well I got an old black with a pinch of
blue in it I tried this as well oh I see
now they make it appear black it's kind
of a dark blue kind of desaturated a
little bit yeah reduce the chroma I know
I just
yellow right yeah just put the original
logo besides so we can compare I hide
all the junk was too much junk yes
so these are the final options great job
and I also got some some applications
some mock-ups of course here we go
everybody's revving their hands together
like here we go it comes the mock-ups
Batista's say my god this is very
balanced
nicely done before after okay let me
just look at this every look at this let
us know in the comments right now if
you're watching us live there's 250 of
you guys watching us live the one on the
left is the before obviously because it
says before at the bottom it's for NEC
civil engineers soccer club and it's a
shield so taking you really quickly
through the process
Marcus was just really interested in
simplifying and making things read
better reducing the amount of details
and you can see instead of showing the
span of the bridge in the way the
original has so many lines of the
suspension he just reduced it down and
then he cut out certain elements of the
bridge to give it a slightly dimensional
feel and I love that it feels very retro
feels very nostalgic and I like it a lot
so very simple top he's reduced that
down and having a little point at the
end not not too sharp but a little point
kind of adds a little something to it
the other one feels a little blunt then
the soccer ball is down there at the
bottom I think for me I really like this
I think the soccer ball maybe just
doesn't read quite like a soccer ball it
just needs a little more love there but
I really really like what you've done
civil is really nice big bold it reads
from a mile away
we've added a little lightning bolts
kind of just thinking about elements and
he sees a little small in here I don't
know how important NEC is but I like it
very balanced very centered it feels
like an instant classic already well
well done
well thank you yet classy is what people
are saying number two looks dope only
the NEC needs to be moved down a little
bit for balance whatever okay why didn't
I receive no I'm not gonna be that sorry
I don't know why you don't receive
notifications hit the bell hit the bell
it's pretty straightforward okay let's
let's take a look at anything else you
got you got your applications right yes
I'm ready here's the unveiling okay okay
what is this is this on yeah a t-shirt
okay Jersey nice noise what has you got
and then I got Jim
look at that oh man okay okay of all the
rocks all the marks the flag with a
smoke in the stadium really captures it
it really does I didn't know civil
engineers were so passionate about
football
this is really good there's you know
when you pick the right image it just
communicates a lot of emotion it really
does it just feels like I'm there I'm
really excited I can hear the drums
beating people chanting or whatever they
chant love it
all right yeah that's it that's it good
job everybody
let's give Marcus a big round of
applause everybody
okay let me get back into my deck now
why Marcus stops sharing so you and we
are so up up next up next is elder Pina
elder Pina from Portugal I believe and
the logo is for fun box for fun box and
he deals up this already looks really
fun I wonder what the deal is gonna do
with this Marc what would you do if you
pick this one would you try to make a
little bit more serious or what yes yeah
how do you say your last name can you
pronounce your last name one more time
say yes I admit by saying that you know
what I was thinking just kind of my
American English butchering of your last
name I was like I was envisioning you
like a valley girl in California and
it's like how you feeling I'm mod yeah
okay nobody got that much lovely to see
you okay she is there screen shared are
we ready to go
her screen share okay he'll take us on a
journey on a funbox journey yeah it's
gonna be a fun project everybody can't
wait waiting with bated breath here
yeah so this is a local by Elder FINA
it's called fun box it's a
family-friendly affordable 3d printer
and I want to start by saying I uploaded
the project on B hands but as a draft
I didn't publish it yet mm-hmm just to
show everyone how they can upload their
projects I see because many people ask
me how to how do I upload my projects
how do i stylize the representation so
we're gonna go through this together and
after we fit publish the project oh wow
look at that she's integrating a live
component to this show I love it you're
getting a lot of heart live demo there's
a lot of a lot of heart emojis coming in
the top in the chat window right now
mm-hmm
they can't wait and there's no no
because notifications this time she just
had her own sound effect going so let's
start this is the original logo mm-hmm
I really liked it but I thought that it
was not balanced enough okay a space
here and here and the smile under the V
and the ole makes it it feels like it's
gonna tilt to the left
okay I see the fulcrum is too far to the
right I started researching 3d printers
and I decided to make a decision making
or decision science for the research
that I've done so a 3d printers they
mainly are rectangular or squared
yes avinasi with the a filament threads
of plastic are heated and then the
software tells of the machine how to
apply the melted plastic
okay why are you telling us about 3d
printers is that what from what I see we
do printer it's targeted for families
and kids I see okay so it was very
important for me to understand 3d
printers more this is part of my
research to decide the direction I'm
gonna go with
so almost all 3d printers the this like
this one okay so I decided that I'm
gonna go with purely geometrical shapes
for two reasons the boxes from the name
and from the devices look like squares
and rectangles okay and because they use
filaments which are lines I also studied
the movement of the nozzle mm-hmm it
goes vertical in a slow motion
and so because in shorter horizontal
movements also to build the products
okay this is all very important and the
building of the identity that I designed
for they look and the last thing is the
the major position of the nozzle and the
final product is centered in alignment
to the box okay mm-hmm so and this is a
brand personality mm-hmm because it's
targeted targeted to kids but it's also
targeted to their families and for teens
and preteens
so the be too funky or too childish or
to organic this is gonna be a very
geometrical design it's gonna be both
smart it needs to cater to all age
groups or for kids and I broke down the
shapes to geometrical shapes and built a
mood board of a building block building
blocks so the so that the entire design
is gonna be based on the idea
geometrical shapes and building blocks
okay got it
and here are some local explorations mmm
I did
I wanted this form I needed to the logo
to be more balanced than than being in a
long format okay and horizontal format
so I did some logo explorations this
took I think maybe three days or more I
see this longer parts I have a video of
the local reading that I did okay I
started with the square of course arted
with grid of course and a one square it
doesn't matter how what are the
dimensions of the square people ask this
all the time is it 1 centimeter or it's
a square ladies and gentlemen but is it
1.5 centimeters or is it 1 centimeter it
doesn't matter it's a box
yeah it doesn't matter as long as you
stick to the ratios between these
squares and the lines yes this the whole
concept of reading mm-hmm
so I'm starting to build the the type I
didn't use a type for this for this
local I build it early from scratch
because it's basically built on
geometrical shapes with the very area
you have a very low x height on this one
right yeah no no is it square so it had
to be a little bit bulky mmm and now
we're building the letter A you just
using shapes and Pathfinder mm-hmm and
the snapped of it helps a lot
this is the letter n two horizontal
lines and then this one I colored it so
I can see the intersection just moved it
a little bit of course this this is not
how actually I'd started designing this
this is after practicing maybe at least
seven to ten times practicing for the
show you practice or just from previous
experience try just to make the video oh
wow the spacing between the letters and
how to build actual letters because it's
required some trial a trial and error I
see
thanks for disclosing that some people
think oh my god everything is perfect
you all cannot make one wrong step
nobody heard I know don't worry
it deals perfect okay I'll take that
from here
okay so now you're drawing the B is that
right throwing the that it's a spaces
inside the letter B okay I see okay
everything is built on grid right that's
the the most interesting for it and
you're taking boxes in your rounding the
corners using the radius tool right your
simple tools yeah
building the squares
Pathfinder at the direct selection
mm-hmm nothing and now we're building
the X mm-hmm take to a 20 to 45 degree
angle and then reflect it
and then we're going to use the
Pathfinder to it again just to clear the
these itches
you see clear the edges right yeah okay
I thought you see clear the itches and
I'm like that's an interesting way to
describe the process she's clearing the
itch it's itching her these corners are
out what she wants oh interesting
texture okay everything needs to be
perfectly aligned yeah
and this is the OL of the box
but I did standard oh I did the Box it's
just the same minimal box hmm the chat
went super quiet I think they're just
watching an admiration right now they're
speechless
yeah let's you know so this is the one
that got the from the video but I
cleaned it a little bit hmm
just a little bit of refinement it says
fun box the O is an abstract square
mm-hmm I think the 3d printer itself and
then I found that from the original logo
it has it had a smile yes which
reference for fun and I like I wanted to
keep the smile in it mm-hm
oh nice I thought you're gonna put that
in the box but you put it on a you
really good yeah I started in the logo
explorations I added it in the box but I
was afraid of the eligibility because
when you when it's too small or very
small it's not gonna show mm-hmm well
this is this this emphasizes the
importance of reading so this you know I
didn't cut the smile in the you just
randomly it's from the one of the exes
okay yes and then here it is and this is
the final local nice it's a pure
geometrical shape
it is our friends of building blocks but
we're not gonna stop now of course we're
not you would not be you if you stop
right now okay let's just be clear this
is part one of 45 guys hang in there a
little more you know she had five hours
of sleep this would be totally different
guys come on Orcas this is a mock-up on
a 3d printer mm-hmm
engraved it can be embossed yeah I like
that there it looks like there's two
finishes a matte and a gloss yeah and
this is the color palette these are the
filaments used in the 3d printers the
plastic filaments so I took my color
palette from them mm-hmm here are the
building blocks I was talking about
these are references of the products
that I printed but in a very abstract
and minimal designs
no but no building blocks are gonna go
into the logo because this is a dynamic
local this is what I like to do most of
my projects are dynamic logos and and
dynamic identities meaning the local can
change doesn't have just one form mm-hmm
and you can use all of them any of them
according to the and the shapes are the
original 3d printer reference amongst so
you have the products are representing
the the box mm-hmm they're part of the
dynamic local and here you go
oh it's reanimate a gift yeah nice you
use it logos mm-hmm
all of these are the local I mean the
the one with the square I think that's a
strength of the logo that you designed
that it's very geometric and it's it
works and it reads and so that you can
have some you can have fun with
expanding the system
yeah yeah it's very expandable because
using this grid just them you can draw
anything inside it any other shape you
can expand to 100 shapes it doesn't
matter mm-hmm stick to the grading
system in this box okay fun of geometry
mm-hmm here are some the part of the
identity are stickers and Friends oh
nice
okay using the colors and then I built a
pattern that's like a strip from from
the building blocks to place on packages
can you pause here for a second I really
like that box on the bottom where you
have this white clean stripe against
this colorful background
it feels playful but it's also
sophisticated and it's hard to strike
that balance it's giving me idea for an
assignment that must send to the young
guns how they can design packaging for
something that would appeal to kids
because it's easy to go high-end upscale
organic super sophisticated and use all
the printing techniques it's very hard
to thread this needle being
sophisticated and playful and I think
you've done an excellent job there well
thank you Chris this was the hardest
part because I wanted to talk later to
little children and to teens
mm-hmm or maybe kids in the in the early
twenties oh so they don't want it to be
too childish right so building these
patterns helped a lot did you just first
for that lowest-rated first I didn't
understand yeah Jonah can you ask your
question where clearly did you build the
box first or that strip on the right
first this is part of the identity you
built the identity first and then you do
the applications but I like to present
this remember this is a Meehan
presentation sure so I need to show the
the strip that I designed from the
building blocks implemented on actual
products and this is the other
so I poke typography the typography
design mm-hmm and fun is replicated in
an outline to give you a clean clean
design print your imagination is some
sort of a tagline you wrote that
yeah nice you know I like that okay hold
on go back up a little bit I like that
you have this outline version of fun
like fun have fun like it's like it's
working on it and it feels it from the
bottom to the top now that whole
explanation at the beginning how you
research how these 3d printers work and
you guys know the filament spins from
the bottom and it works its way up right
so that's how it's being filled in from
the bottom to the top so in a graphic
way you're hinting at how it's made and
it's very smart design really good job
thank you Chris this is this is exactly
what you said this is the importance of
the decision-making slide not having
things centered and in vertical
application mm-hmm and again the font is
montserrat
one of my favorites and I've read in the
comments that many people said it's one
of their favorites yes this is
coincidental both you guys are using
montserrat right yeah all right very
well because it's an elegant elegant
font that is also very geometric font to
use on the logo I built it from scratch
so I chose a font that could be very
close a good complement yeah yes and the
part of the identity I took the building
blocks and gave it a one color mm-hmm it
goes behind designs I'll show some
applications
here's another yeah yeah hey people like
the gifts keep them coming
it's a dynamic local needs I like that
it cycles through that's pretty cool
oh and the watch is an Apple watch
because it has an application one of the
implementations of
this project should be digital and on a
software digital watch and a website a
mobile application is some billboards
that's using the same skateboard okay
now you talked about language talking my
language right now that's skateboard
yeah this is the strip here's the
pattern another one and the stickers are
a huge part of the identity because
stickers can attract people and they
will ask each other especially kids
what are these whatever they reflect and
they they will tell them about the
business here are some posters wall
posters okay look at these things so the
dynamic local you don't have to use the
same logo every time you can any one of
the variations and they people were
related to the main logo immediately as
long as you're consistent really smart
here I want to break down the posters
for one second ooh can you go back so
you're showing the 3d printed object and
you're using kind of a monotone duotone
way to represent each object that you're
building so that's the result of what
you do and you're showing the smile of
the person the reaction or emotional
thing I also like how you crop the
person as if the person is being 3d
printed too and you put the funbox on
top a lot of sophisticated thinking
going on in here I like it
good job okay Chris is the app icon I
took the you and the smile I made it
doesn't you don't need the entire logo
to be in here mm-hmm
okay there are some three years later
another variation of how you can use the
logo and fast UI design that imagination
digital magic and it's
rent it let's go it would be of course
animated I didn't animate that one
second I want a prompt everybody's
watching us all 320 of you guys that are
still on the livestream with this how
many more applications does ideal have
left scroll just put a type of a number
like it's gonna end no it's not anything
and it's just like fire fire fire emoji
okay kind of one but I usually tell tell
people until designers don't go over six
mock-ups yeah but when if it's needed
yes I know why tell designers do that
you guys the reason why I deal says do
not do more than six applications for
your mock-ups is because when she comes
on the show she's in 236 and she's gonna
embarrass you very much okay
let's go let's go last one what are we
doing okay okay and this is the final
dynamic logo that it is awesome great
job everybody right oh please I'm
standing so there's a standing ovation
for you I'm automatically doing that the
guy should get out but that's okay now
really amazing thorough job it's almost
like we can't call this logo therapy
anymore we have to call this brand
identity designer era P because it's too
much it's just it's exploding at the
seams I don't even know I just can't
even imagine what he was gonna do for us
the next time she comes on his show
it'll be a four-hour show 1,700 mock-ups
and applications she wrote the ad
campaign she's designed a website and
she built the app and it's working is
functional it's like it's just through
the roof okay gonna send us one example
she actually built a 3d printer just for
the show okay a lot of questions coming
in but first but first I needed to take
a look at your final logo I had a few
things in there that I was like I just
want to look at it real tight can we do
that
yeah can you jump into AI for me or did
or that's not possible
no no okay I want to go full sue now we
get to see what's the magic behind the
curtain okay we've even tighter just
zoom in let's fill that sucker up to the
screen cuz I'm looking at a monitor
that's my eyesight sounds good okay
there were some questions from people
I'm just gonna let you know what what
they're saying
cuz I read your comments everybody that
they thought that F was a little bit on
the low the crossbar I don't have a
problem with that it's like I said it
was a lower X height you know but it's
cool it's got a fun vibe to it so it
fits within the world of the product the
the target market that you're focusing
on everything's great
the X there like there's some comments
like they didn't like 2x I like 2x a lot
it's unusual because if you cut it off
the normal way you do an X it just
becomes another another letter I like it
here's where I'm having some problems
the B the B the way that the the top
bowl of the B it tapers in that little
point that connects between the top and
the bottom of the B feels yes I I would
just say optically I would pull that out
to the right to kind of make that more
balanced you know so it will take a
little bit of work but somewhere in
there will be a really balanced B I
already feeling a little bit better
about that right now
and I don't want to part direct you how
to do this but I really just blown away
just like things come on my ears right
now it's like wow really great job just
tremendous I'm scared to invite you back
on the show because you will have no
time left for real work because all
you'll be doing is future episodes with
us this is so amazing thank you so much
right all right very good job I'm just
curious for both of you guys first
questions about mock-ups I would love to
ask you guys next time to do a little
video on one of the more challenging
mock-ups that you do because everybody
seeing this it's amazing and then it's
like you guys disappear
and then you come back Magos so they
want to know how you did the mock-ups
and maybe you guys can just talk us
through this so I'm gonna kick it back
to Marcus first and we'll return to a
deal and then we'll wrap up the show so
Marcus how did you do that flag in the
stadium where'd you get the image from
and how did you do that can we do with a
deal first okay will do
deal first okay so a deal in terms of
your mock-up which one was the most
challenging for you to do and can you
talk us through the process you have to
show it but just talk us through it it's
a very simple thing first you get really
good mock-ups ready-made ones okay I'm
just it the file in Photoshop if you
feel like the lighting is not doing you
good or something see myself just like
the t-shirt on the barrel I got the hair
from Shutterstock and I added the
defense that I did and this of the
pattern but generally get good mock-ups
buy them buy them and is the source that
you go to the buy mock-ups woke up
poured welcome what mock-up word world
really look at that dropping resources
on you guys are in a mock-up world okay
and where else
there's another one it's called yellow
pages Oh yellow pages and you can find
good good free ones on graphic burger as
well mm-hmm yes I know I'm from the
little Catholic burger so many good
websites for for free ones but the free
ones get how do you say used by everyone
they are used by every I see a unique
enough yeah so some mock-ups I always
set a budget and I invest in fronting
and mock-ups they as I say every time
mock-up cells but really markup cells
alright there we go they do they really
do because what you're doing is when you
design a logo when you design a logo
it couldn't be very simple in its
execution and then the clients are like
well why did I pay you all that money
you take that same logo you put it on a
waving flag you put on the side of a
building you put it around a package
like wow you're a genius I'm glad I paid
you so much it really comes down today
it's really weird it's about closing the
imagination gap because people aren't
great at visualizing especially non
creatives non-designers okay so that's
definitely something you want to do so I
want to just recap a little bit about
what I feel is saying if you get the
free ones which is totally fine
as you're starting out because you don't
have a lot of money just by the free
mock-ups they're built for you just swap
out files and it works so the problem
then there's everybody uses the same
free ones and so then your work starts
to look like everybody else's so if you
go and buy some of the the ones that
cost money at least you there's a better
selection usually and there's oftentimes
they're built a little bit better so you
have a little bit more ability to tweak
them and change colors or change the
lighting and they usually provide
several finishes like different gold or
metallic finishes and you can do that so
you invest a little bit in the mock-ups
and it go a long way mockup sells
according to a deal and I agree 100%
markup worldcom yellowpages.com we don't
make any money off that and graphic
burger you guys can look that up so
she'll listen yes yellow images right
yes yellow images I thought you came up
with a new one it's videos personal
library yellow pages yeah yellow images
is amazing they just look it up look it
up okay now I guess then really what
you're saying to me and I want to make a
point of this is that when you're
designing it's the designer who's trying
to find the right mock-up to tell the
story that is appropriate that really
captures the imagination and fires up
your client and that's really your job
so building it is a chore and not
necessarily good use of your time now if
none exists go build one but if they
exists already just find the right one
in art direct and put it in the last
question I want to ask you is this
before we turn it back to Marcus is this
is to do such thorough work like this if
this were for a real client how much
would you charge to do this so I'm
raising my prices okay and there's the
last couple of months mhm
used to charging five case for locals
mm-hmm and aiming to start a 10k 10k
okay so do to do this work moving
forward and we're moving forward well we
only look forward to the future right if
you want to hire a deal and you want her
to do this kind of really amazing a
sense of research and design exploration
and mock-ups
everything it's gonna cost you 10 K
right no deal as a as a token of my
appreciation for you the next time a
client calls you and you need help call
me I'll negotiate for you I'll get you a
lot more money than that okay agreed
okay so just let me know and we'll work
it out my schedule I'm not just saying
that I really do mean it if you need me
to help you negotiate I can get you more
money than what you're getting and I
like to see that I like to see a a woman
a woman from someplace other than
America doing this amazing work and
doing what you're doing it's fantastic
and you really reinforce the message
that I've been saying out there which is
the global design market is incredible
now what we need to do is get everybody
in the larger design community outside
of the Western markets to get the same
fair pay same value same worth as
everybody else in the world and that's
one of my missions okay so I'm just
really thrilled to see you do what you
do you're proving a point for me so
thank you very much now let's start
return back to Marcus Marcus how'd you
do your mock-up man um basically it's
exactly the same as images or graphic
Berger and the nest royalty flag yes
this actually was mocked up from Behance
so there's a couple of free sport really
yeah I don't even know that was true Wow
mock-ups of behance yeah Wow look at
that
you guys made something new every single
day okay very good
Wow okay so do I assume correctly that
you have a subscription to yellow images
because it's a lot cheaper to have a sub
right my just I just the t-shirt mock-up
I just discovered yesterday so you just
bought one okay yeah yeah if you buy the
subscription I think it's super cheap
and they'll build custom ones for you
yeah yeah because a friend of mine
turned me onto yellow images and they
will I you know how to do this they'll
build a custom one for you if they don't
have what you what you want amazing okay
Marcus really great job a deal great job
you guys look when you pick that shield
I'm just gonna be really honest like God
every single time like why do they pick
these ones like it's so complicated how
can they make this one better and every
single time you guys deliver thank you
very much and I want to appreciate every
single person who's tuned in today to
watch the two of you work and share your
process so I'm asking on the behalf of
our entire audience please next time
show us a little bit about how you're
doing your mock ups I know it's very
easy for you guys to do maybe you can
even show us how you're looking for them
and when you find the right one what you
do with it just so they can see how easy
it is those of us that use markups on a
regular basis especially ones that you
pay for that you don't have to build
from scratch we realize it's super easy
to swap the file out and you're good to
go so for a lot of people who don't know
what that is let's just show them next
time okay all right thank you very much
we're gonna wrap up the show we went a
little bit long today and we had a false
start but thank you very much for
everybody tuning in if you want to know
how to get your logo critiqued I'm gonna
tell you right now if you're having a
case of FOMO fear of missing out make
sure you go to the futures Facebook page
the future on Facebook there's a post it
says submit your logo to be critiqued
and a deal and every and Marcus and
everybody else that's part of the
logotherapy crew will be looking through
there combing through so make sure you
submit make sure you submit and they're
looking for something that catches their
eye okay and that's it for us today you
guys make sure you guys like comment
subscribe if you want to be notified hit
that Bell icon loving everybody that's
part of this community whether you get
sustaining member or not still
appreciate you thanks for being part of
the Future fam part of the donation
let's get out of here where's my music
see you guys later thank you very much
everybody
[Music]